TONE OF THEIR VOICE, THEIR
EMOTION AND EXACTLY WHAT THEY
ARE SAYING.
>> LAST NIGHT NIKKI HALEY, ONCE
A RISING STAR ON THE TPOP, MORE
LIKE A REPUBLICAN PINBALL
MACHINE SAID THIS AT THE RONALD
REAGAN LIBRARY.
>> A LARGE PORTION OF OUR PEOPLE
ARE PLAGUED BY SELF-DOUBT OR
EVEN BY HATRED OF AMERICA.
IT'S A PANDEMIC MUCH MORE
DAMAGING THAN ANY VIRUS.
>> THE FORMER AMBASSADOR TO THE
U.N. NOT LETTING MORE THAN
700,000 COVID DEATHS AND
COUNTING GET IN THE WAY OF
MINIMIZING A PANDEMIC
POLITICIZED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION SHE SERVED AS SHE
SUGGESTS LIBERALS HATE AMERICA
AND THE COUNTRY DOESN'T HAVE A
RACISM PROGRAM, AS SHE RECOUNTED
GROWING UP IN THE SOUTH.
>> AND TAKE IT FROM ME, THE
FIRST FEMALE AND FIRST MINORITY
GOVERNOR OF SOUTH CAROLINA,
AMERICA IS NOT A RACIST COUNTRY.
AS A BROWN GIRL GROWING UP IN A
SMALL SOUTHERN TOWN, I SAW THE
PROMISE OF AMERICA UNFOLD BEFORE
ME.
>> SHE DID SEE THE PROMISE OF
AMERICA UNFOLD.
BUT AT TIMES SHE ALSO SAW THE
PROMISE OF AMERICA DENIED.
AND WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE SHE'S
TALKED ABOUT IT, GROWING UP
WHERE SHE AND HER SIKH INDIAN
IMMIGRANTS DIDN'T BLEND IN.
>> WE WERE ALWAYS OTHER.
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE GROWING UP
WHAT LESSONS DID IT TEACH YOU?
>> I THINK YOU GROW UP IN A
SMALL TOWN AND YOUR FATHER ONCE
A TURBAN, MOTHER WEARS A SARI.
MY PARENTS REMINDED ABOUT HOW
YOU'RE DIFFERENT.
IT'S ABOUT HOW YOU'RE SIMILAR.
>> YOU WOULD SEE PEOPLE STARING
AT YOUR DAD.
AND ONE PLACE THE POLICE WERE
CALLED BECAUSE HE WAS SHOPPING
AT A ROAD SIDE STAND.
AND YOU SAID IT MADE YOU SAD FOR
HIM.
>> I KNEW THEY DIDN'T KNOW HIM
THE WAY I KNEW HIM.
AND I KNEW THEY WERE -- WHATEVER
FEAR OR CONCERN THEY HAD I KNEW
WASN'T WARRANTED.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WHILE I
TALK ABOUT THOSE DIFFERENCES,
IT'S IN THAT ENVIRONMENT, IN
THAT STATE OF SOUTH CAROLINA
THAT I WATCHED THEM CHANGE.
I SAW THE EVOLUTION.
I SAW HOW THEY --
>> THE PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY,
NO THE YOUR PARENTS.
>>> RIGHT.
THEY WANTED TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
OUR FAMILY.
>> SOME PEOPLE DIDN'T CHANGE,
THOUGH.
LIKE ONE SOUTH CAROLINA STATE
SENATOR WHO SAID THIS IN 2010 AS
SHE RAN FOR GOVERNOR.
>> WE'VE GOT A RAG HEAD IN
WASHINGTON.
WE DON'T NEED A RAG HEAD IN THE
STATEHOUSE.
>> BACKLASH AGAINST THAT VIDEO
HELPED PROPEL HALEY TO VICTORY.
SYSTEMIC RACISM IS IN THE PAST
NOW, WHICH SHE SAID AS GOVERN
OFR SOUTH CAROLINA WHEN THEY
REMOVED THE CONFEDERATE FLAG
FROM THE STATE HOUSE GROUNDS.
HERE SHE IS IN 2014.
>> WE REALLY KIND OF FIXED ALL
THAT WHEN YOU ELECTED THE FIRST
INDIAN FEMALE GOVERNOR.
THAT SENT A HUGE MESSAGE.
.
>> THE NEXT YEAR, A WHITE
SUPREMACIST WALKED INTO THE
EMANUEL AME CHURCH, JOINED
PRESCRIPTIONERS FOR BIBLE STUDY
AND PULLED OUT A GUN AND
EXECUTED NINE OF THEM.
WHEN ASKED BY CBS NEWS ABOUT
REMOVING THE CONFEDERATE FLAG
SHE SAID IT WASN'T THE RIGHT
TIME.
>> RIGHT NOW I AM NOT DOING THAT
TO THE PEOPLE OF MY STATE.
>> IN LESS THAN A WEEK, TO HER
CREDIT, THE GOVERNOR CAME
AROUND.
>> IT'S TIME TO MOVE THE FLAG
FROM THE CAPITOL GROUNDS.
ON MATTERS OF RACE, SOUTH
CAROLINA HAS A TOUGH HISTORY.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
MANY OF US HAVE SEEN IT IN OUR
OWN LIVES AND THE LIVES OF OUR
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS.
WE DON'T NEED REMINDERS.
IN SPITE OF LAST WEEK'S TRAGEDY,
WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY SINCE
THOSE DAYS AND HAVE MUCH TO BE
PROUD OF, BUT THERE'S MORE WE
CAN DO.
>> THERE IS MORE TO DO, SHE
SAID.
WORTH NOTING WHILE DYLANN ROOF
WAS CONVICTED ON FEDERAL HATE
CRIME CHARGES, HE DID NOT FACE
STATE HATE CRIME CHARGES BECAUSE
SOUTH CAROLINA DIDN'T HAVE A
HATE CRIMES LAW AND STILL
DOESN'T.
SIT ONE OF TWO STATES WITHOUT
ONE.
AN ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN IN SOUTH
CAROLINA URGING RESIDENTS TO
REPORT HATE CRIMES.
IN LAST NIGHT'S SPAOEFRPBGS THE
FORMER GOVERNOR WHO REMOVED THE
CONFEDERATE FLAG FROM THE
STATEHOUSE GROUNDS ONLY TO HAVE
THAT SYMBOL BRANDISHED INSIDE
THE U.S. CAPITOL BY RIOTERS THIS
PAST JANUARY, WHITEWASHED THE
UPS AND DOWNS OF THE AMERICAN
EXPERIENCE WITH RACISM AND THE
CHALLENGES STILL AHEAD, ALL
APPARENTLY TO APPEAL TO THE
CONSERVATIVE BASE.
NIKKI HALEY COURTING THE
FOLLOWERS OF DONALD TRUMP WHO
ENLISTED THE SUPPORT OF
ANTI-GOVERNMENT EXTREMISTS, TOLD
THE PROUD BOYS TO STAND BACK AND
STAND BY, TOLD BLACK AND BROWN
NATIONS SHUT HOLE COUNTRIES AND
SAID THERE ARE VERY FINE PEOPLE
ON BOTH SIDES AFTER A WHITE
SUPREMACIST KILLED A WOMAN AS
SHE PROTESTED A FAR RIGHT RALLY
EVEN AFTER NIKKI HALEY SAID THIS
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP FOLLOWING
JANUARY 6th.
WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE HE LET US
DOWN.
HE WENT DOWN A PATH HE SHOULDN'T
HAVE.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE FOLLOWED HIM.
AND WE SHOULDN'T HAVE LISTENED
TO HIM.
AND WE CAN'T LET THAT EVER
HAPPEN AGAIN.
HIS ACTIONS SINCE ELECTION DAY
WILL BE JUDGED HARSHLY BY
HISTORY.
SHE WENT TO MAR-A-LAGO TO KISS
THE RING BUT SHE WAS DENIE